hey guys i'm still unemployed so let's
solve another leak code problem today
leak code 2
add two numbers together so just like
the problem
says all we're really doing is adding
two numbers together right so like
this example 342 465
add them together right that's 807. well
you probably remember from elementary
school how to add two numbers together
right so that's
the number one thing to know about this
problem right so
we're adding 342 and 465.
so do you remember how to add two
numbers together from elementary school
you probably do but you might think you
don't so
let's just look at this right two plus
five that's seven
four plus six that's ten but that's a
two digit number right so we gotta
take a carry for that so we'll put a
zero here
but we know we have a carry so we're
gonna have to put that one
over here right so now we have one plus
three plus four
that's eight so we just did it right
that was the result
807 so you do probably remember how to
add two numbers together that's really
the main part of this problem now the
second
thing to recognize though of this
problem is
that there's a lot of edge cases that's
kind of why there's a lot of dislikes in
this problem
you can tell over here but so there's
going to be a lot of edge cases and
we're going to
really talk about those edge cases and
focus on them
so the first thing they tell us is we're
given two non-empty linked lists
right so these linked lists are
representing the integers
that we're adding together so they're
non-empty what does that mean for us
that means if we're adding two numbers
right
like uh 500 plus
something else right this second number
it can't be empty there's always gonna
be some number here right so like eight
for example something like that
it's never going to be empty the other
thing is that they're
non-negative integers that's really
convenient for us
because these are linked lists remember
so having a negative number would kind
of be inconvenient so good thing we
don't have to worry about that
the other thing is the digits are stored
in reverse
order now let's not worry about this too
much yet
so for example we see 342
down here in 465 right in the linked
lists
they're stored in reverse order so 342
is actually 243. uh 465
is actually 564. so
we'll see we'll see later that having
them in reverse order actually helps us
and so we want to add these two numbers
and return it as a
linked list so for each digit we're
going to have to create a separate
node so we we will keep that in mind
so let's look at a slightly modified
example in the
in the example given both the numbers
had the exact same number of digits
right so there were three digits in each
but we're looking at it slightly
different we added one more digit
to one of the numbers because this is
kind of
a case that you have to consider so the
first thing we're gonna do
is obvious right we're just adding two
numbers together so we're gonna
go iterate through them right so five
plus two that's gonna be 7 right that's
our
first node and notice that we're
starting
at the ones place right because that's
how you add numbers
and since the lists these linked lists
are given to us
in reverse order it makes it really easy
for us to start at the ones place
that's how you add two numbers together
so they really made it easy for us
so next we're just gonna basically keep
doing that right so now we're gonna get
to the next
two numbers add them together that's
going to be 10 so we're going to
remember
that we have to put a carry so we'll
have a zero here and we'll
make sure to remember we have a carry so
now we're gonna do one plus four plus
three
that's eight now we no longer have a
carry so the carry's gone
and now we get to a weird place right
there's nothing here
so we only have one node right so what
are we gonna say is up here well we can
just kind of
uh assume that it's a zero right so
there's not actually any value but we'll
assume that there's a zero here
so zero plus three that's going to be
three
and in this case this is going to be our
result so we just considered one edge
case of what if the two
linked lists that we're adding together
are of different sizes right
so we kind of know what we can do in
that case now there's one last edge case
that's kind of tricky
i seem to never remember it when i'm
solving this problem but
maybe you'll be able to catch it so
let's say we were adding
seven plus eight together right now when
you add it together
with addition right it's pretty obvious
uh let me rewrite it
so we know it's 15 right so we're going
to put a
5 here but we have a carry so the carry
is going to go here right but there's no
other number that we're adding here
right
we know we can just put the 1 here but
when you're solving this algorithm you
might forget to do that because
with a linked list seven plus eight
you add these together you get a five
right that's our result
and you'll put the carry here you'll say
yeah there's a carry of one
but in our algorithm we have to make
sure to remember
to put the one in our result
right even if there aren't any uh nodes
here right like there aren't any
input nodes that we're adding it with so
with all of that in mind let's actually
get into the code and it'll probably
make even more sense
so the first thing we want to do is we
know we're creating a resulting linked
list so
i like to just put a dummy node to not
have to deal with any of the edge cases
of inserting into a linked list
and our current pointer is going to
point at the position that we're going
to be inserting
a new node or the new digit into
so we're going to iterate through these
nodes now how long
are we going to be iterating through
them while either of them has a digit so
while
l1 or l2 is non-null we're going to be
adding them together
now we know one of them could be null so
we're going to get the digits from them
v1 is going to be the digit of list one
only if l1 is non-null if l1
is null though we're gonna set it to
zero right just like we did
in our visual example we're gonna do the
exact same thing
for v2
now we actually want to add them
together but
hold on remember we had a carry that we
have to maintain
so i'm gonna have a carry value and
initially set it to zero outside of our
loop so carry is initially zero
so now we're gonna compute the new digit
so how do we do that well we'll say
v1 plus v2 plus carry right this is
elementary school mathematics but now we
could potentially have a
new carry right so if our number that we
just computed for example what if it's
right so that's a two digit number so
we're we want to get the carry out of
that so how do we get it
uh we can just say value
divided by 10. also since
our value could be greater than 10 right
right like 15
we want only the the ones place
digit so we're gonna take our value and
mod it by ten so that'll give us the
ones place
so now that we have the digit we can
finally insert it into our list so we're
going to say
current.next we're going to insert a new
list node
with the value that we just computed so
now we're going to be
updating our pointers so we have to
update current
so we're going to set current to the
next pointer
we're going to update our list one and
list two pointers
if they are non-null so l1 is going to
be
l1 dot next if l1 is non-null
else we can leave it as null
right you might you might say okay now
we're done we're just going to return
dummy.next right so we're going to
return the list that we just created
but remember that edge case that we
talked about right what if we had
eight plus seven uh our loop
is is going to stop and we're going to
forget about the carry
so over here i'm going to add one last
thing to our condition
while our loop is going if our carry is
non-null
we want to continue the loop meaning if
our carry for example 8 plus 7
l1 and l2 are going to be null meaning
v1 and v2 are going to evaluate to 0
but our carry is going to be 1 right
so we're gonna say uh we're gonna insert
a value of zero
plus zero plus one because our carry is
one and then
of course our list is gonna need to have
that value in it so
don't forget about the edge cases that's
really what makes this problem annoying
i hope this was helpful for you if it
was leave a like and subscribe
and thank you for watching